do y'all remember when Jon Gosselin was
on the cover of magazines he had a book
deal
he and Kate were making millions of
dollars they were actually the hottest
couple in reality TV but that was then
our senior news editor Jennifer pero
spent a day with John and let's just say
that life hasn't been the same after the
fame this is your neighborhood
laundromat okay kid how often you here
uh two times a week John says he leads
the normal life he always has including
everyday chores I didn't buy a watch on
Daria like I have to do laundry like you
meet so many different people in
laundromat and they're like hey aren't
you I'm like everybody's got to do
laundry parents to a set of twins and
sextuplets John and Kate put their life
out there for John and Kate Plus eight
but they divorced in 2009 I don't really
talk to my ex-wife so it's all kind of
just helter skelter like I have my life
and she has her life and we have our
life with our kids it's text and that's
it and that's it was let's all stress
offering prison oh I see her in person
like at the bus stop and stuff but I
don't talk to her it's all just you know
Hannah yet it's something I hate her
just I just don't talk
the paparazzi used to chase him down
today
he's relieved not to be hounded in his
hometown of Reading Pennsylvania and he
wishes he had a better relationship with
his 15 year old twin daughters Matt and
Tara I don't see that much or often I'm
we're kind of not talking right now the
kids that I do get are Hannah Leah Joel
and Aaden sometimes I get Alexis but not
often and then call and I haven't seen
for a really long time
I mean I go to the house to pick them up
I can't trespass hey give me my kids and
it doesn't work I mean I'd have to go to
court every single time so I'm I'm
figuring all that out right now as I get
more stable in my life in my career
financially we asked for Kate to weigh
in on John's comment but neither she or
her reps responded by our deadline like
any single dad when the kids visit John
does the cooking when the kids come it's
probably anywhere from 150 to about $225
in groceries but I get him at the
grocery aisle because I can get like
three times as much and it's discounted
Oh so the the expiration dates are
closer to the time of expiring oh my
gosh yeah while Kate and the kids still
do specials for TLC John earns a living
doing jobs like sales and pursuing his
passion of music by DJ I don't film
anymore so it's like you know I'm not
making a TV salary that I used to you
know people I go once you save that
money I've donated that money to my
ex-wife he did a stint cooking at TGI
Friday saying he did it for fun and
donated his wages to charity because I
work at TGI Fridays who cares what if I
was a plumber would you knock me down
then what if I was a firefighter would
you knock me down then John says he
survived reality Armageddon and accepts
the way life has played out we got
married too young
we're kids super early and I just think
we're two different people
I think TV made it faster you know sped
up our divorce but I think in the long
run they would just move with a split
anyway and surprise keV John told us he
is not finished with television that's
interesting because TV kind of ruined
his life
well he's not done he says he's out
there pitching shows and he hopes to
land a job hosting a series
what's the wall all right